ja diese ganzen fragen habe ich ihnen
noch nicht gestellt damit er uns das
jetzt auf phoenix live erzählen kann
graf lambsdorff mitglied des
bundesvorstands der fdp und auch noch
stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender weil noch das
haben wir eben kurz besprochen ja auch
die neunzehnte legislaturperiode noch
läuft bis zur konstituierung des
bundestags dann ende oktober und meinen
kollegen bonn das haben sie gerade nicht
gehört hat gleich gefragt hatten sie
denn schon kontakt mit den grünen wir
sprechen alle miteinander hier aber die
kontakte laufen jetzt auf der ebene der
parteivorsitzenden und insofern ist das
die maßgebliche schiene auf der
kommuniziert wird für das was jetzt
ansteht okay aber das heißt man versucht
ja auch inoffiziell kontakte zu haben
das hilft ja auch bei solchen
verhandlungen
wie war das so seit gestern abend also
der gestern abend haben wir in aller
erster linie mal gefeiert dann haben wir
uns organisiert wir haben jetzt gerade
eine fraktionssitzung christian linder
ist bestätigt worden mit tollen ergebnis
als fraktionsvorsitzender wir haben
geschaut wie das wahlergebnis im
einzelnen aus da wo wir stark an wo wir
schwach waren was uns besonders gefreut
hat ist dass wir eben bei den
erstwählern an der spitze von allen
parteien lagen das war natürlich
besonders schöne erkenntnis auf der wir
dann sozusagen ein bisschen weitere
analysen aufgebaut haben für die zukunft
also mit anderen worten wir sind im
moment in einem analyse in einem
organisations und in einem feier modus
und der
gesprächskanal der jetzt aufgebaut wird
zwischen dem generalsekretär volker
wissing dem parteivorsitzenden christian
lindner und den proms bei den grünen
frau berg und dann habe ich das ist der
über den dann die gespräche in den
nächsten wochen laufen werden da hat
herr li na ja heute auch schon den neuen
begriff vor sondierungsgespräche geprägt
was erwarten sie was wird in diesen vor
sondierungsgesprächen abgeklopft ehrlich
gesagt müssen die vier das selber glaube
ich noch festlegen man wird sich erst
mal kennenlernen besser man muss
vertrauen aufbauen werden jetzt einen
wahlkampf hinter uns und
leidenschaftlichen wahlkampf wo wir auch
unterschiede herausgearbeitet haben
jetzt geht es darum zu
für herauszufinden wo gibt es
gemeinsamkeiten also wo gibt es felder
wo man übereinstimmungen hat und da gibt
es einige politische felder wo wir bei
den grünen relativ wenig probleme haben
als liberale wenn ich an die familien an
die gesellschaftspolitik denke große
felder der innen und rechtspolitik aber
es gibt andere wo es eben schwieriger
ist und ich glaube dass die vier jetzt
erst mal miteinander abklopfen werden in
welchen formaten wollen wir reden wer
soll welche arbeitsgruppen bilden wie
viele teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer von
beiden parteien pro arbeitsgruppe das
sind zum teil ganz einfache ganz banale
dinge aber das wichtige ist dass jetzt
erst mal vertrauen wächst denn eines ist
klar die nächste bundesregierung so
sieht es jedenfalls derzeit aus wird mit
grünen und liberalen geformt werden
insofern ist es jetzt das einüben einer
zusammenarbeit die wir vier jahre lang
machen wollen was erhoffen sie sich auch
davon wenn sie wie sie jetzt gesagt
haben die beiden kleineren
koalitionspartner erst mal miteinander
sprechen bevor man dann mit spd oder und
union sich zusammensetzt na ja es ist so
und das hat herr habe wie ich finde
richtig gesagt das natürlich bei den
themen der wirtschaft zerstörer der
finanzpolitik auch teilweise der
klimapolitik die position von fdp und
grünen im wahlkampf relativ weit
auseinander lagen und insofern ist es
richtig hier erstmal zwischen den beiden
so hat herr beck das formuliert
konträren parteien die brücken zu bauen
die positionen anzunähern bevor man mit
den anderen redet denn sonst ist man in
einzelgesprächen und muss hinterher
versuchen diese brücken noch zu bauen
das ist mühsamer als es von anfang an zu
machen und dann kann man über die
brücken gehen für die gespräche mit den
anderen möchte man sich vielleicht auch
schon ein bisschen verbünden damit es
nicht wieder zu so situationen kommt wie
2017 in den sondierungsgesprächen wo ja
die fdp das gefühl hatte auf einen
partner wird da viel mehr eingegangen
als auf den anderen das war nicht nur
ein gefühl ich war dabei also das war
die realität und eine solche realität
war eben nicht produktiv damals für die
gespräche das muss man ganz deutlich
sagen und deswegen ist es ganz klar wir
wollen das vermeiden wir wollen zu einer
regierungsbildung kommen auch zu einer
zügigen regierungsbildung kommen denn
die welt wartet ja nicht auf uns im
frühjahr wird in frankreich gewählt wir
haben im nächsten jahr in november in
den usa die midterm wahlen das heißt die
welt dreht sich weiter und deutschland
darf nicht zu lange ausfallen deswegen
wäre es mein wunsch zügigen
regierungsbildung hinzubekommen und da
finde ich den weg den robert habeck
annalena baerbock und christian lindner
gefunden haben nämlich erst mal
miteinander zu reden gut und richtig was
erwarten sie denn wenn es zu gesprächen
kommt was läuft denn da anders wie soll
sollen sich die parteien auf welcher
ebene sollen die sich anders treffen als
vielleicht 2017 sie waren ja wie gesagt
dabei jahr 2017 haben wir eben deutlich
gemerkt dass wir vorher vier jahre nicht
dabei waren und dass sich union und
grüne bereits auf viele positionen
verständigt hatten und von uns erwartet
wurde quasi das fünfte rad am wagen zu
geben das ist eine unglückliche
situation das ist ja auch wenn man
geschäftlich oder oder juristisch
verhandlungen führt ist so etwas immer
eine unglückliche situation denn am ende
des tages in einer koalition muss jeder
partner sich wiederfinden es gibt keine
mehrheit ohne dass alle partner
mitmachen und wenn man dann in seine
verhandlungssituation steckt dann ist
das unglücklich das zu vermeiden das ist
jetzt wirklich die aufgabe der vier um
die es hier geht nicht gerade genannt
habe und ich hoffe dass sie die
erledigen die pflanze herzlichen dank
die fraktionssitzung ist jetzt
anscheinend auch zu ende in herzlichen
dank für das sehr früh raus gekommen
sind und damit geben wir hier von der
fraktionssitzung aus dem deutschen
bundestag ab zum studio in bonn zu
thomas bade